hey guys book back to brand-new video
back on monster world again they're
gonna be talking about extreme behemoth
again and why I think extreme behemoth
might just be a little bit too extreme
for monster on our wall at the moment so
just to recap and get started
Monster Hunter world just released
extreme behemoth into the game and he is
definitely extreme here's a Rhett
opposed to all the current changes that
we no credit to Sten PI as I have the
right up I have referenced this post
twice by now and basically what it reads
is that the char Buddhists or however
you want to pronounce it aka is tornado
attack it's casting so fast before you
can shoot the weapon it can still be but
flash but the window is far shorter hit
the assistant I recommends that someone
has a sword and shield ready so that
they can flash them without receiving
the weapon he also says that his health
is now around 50,000 HP in that his
before helped that and the regular
version is at 35,000 which is a 15k
increase his meteor is now applied
defense down the ecliptic meteor is now
in phase one he only drops two comets in
the first phase and one comment in the
second phase he cannot only be flashed
twice because he's now considered
tempered there's more than three
ecliptic meteors dropped in the last
phase of the flight he has a new entire
move no ecliptic meteor is dropped in
the third phase depending on the
situation that you're in its DPS check
so if we do enough damage he won't drop
one but if he if you don't do enough
damage he will drop one so you'd meet
you need to meet the requirement or he
will cast the ecliptic meteor and you
will have no comets and the fact that
the only thing you're getting is a
layered armor luckily it only does
require one of this glamorous prism item
so thankfully going to do this fight
once and then you get the whole thing
the time limit is now 30 minutes instead
of 35 you get a guild card title called
the warrior of light and the ecliptic
meteor can now be dodged by walking out
of the area although you can still not
far cast out of it these are some crazy
changes and it almost makes the entire
fight completely different now I
understand Monster Hunter is a hard game
in world there's no exception I knew the
game was going to be hard when I first
fought in Oregon save for my first time
but this isn't even remotely close to
that people on reddit are annoyed at
this fight and even in my comments
section when I made a guide explaining
these changes 80% of them of the
comments were [ __ ] this fight or it's
not worth it for the rewards and saying
something like that if you do need to
want if you do want to watch that guide
you can click the link in the top right
if you want to go to that video but the
guild card will probably only be seen if
people actually want
look at your character in the gathering
hub or when you're in a quest and while
the lair armor is a lot more noticeable
it's arguably one of the greatest sets
in the game judged by the community so
most people will assume you just have
the full set and not the layered armor
since it's so good and the roars
personally just aren't good enough and
those are the two rewards some people in
my comment section and on reddit have
suggested that the armor set should
become a gamma set if you if you defeat
extreme behemoths basically meaning the
gammas rich and armored or there should
be some tier 2 extreme stones or
something very valuable in the endgame
of monster hunter world so you can make
a min/max set and get the best that's
possible and not just a layered armor in
a title you also have to understand that
not everyone has a group of mates for
them to hunt with I personally hunt solo
I shown by most of my solo guides in
this game so when there's a team monster
like behemoth or cool to Roth I end up
fighting and queuing up with randoms as
do most people and my teams get carted
before we even finished the first phase
even teams with full communication are
having trouble beating this monster and
the biggest gripe for me is I'm seeing
the same thing for this monster being
used in its cluster bombs it's no see
here cluster bombs are good and are
crazily effective against behemoths and
shown by the multitude of videos on it
at the time I'm recording this one
person has defeated extreme behemoth
solo I believe in about 16 minutes and
that person basically spammed behemoth
with cluster bombs and a mix of other
ammo types here and there but it was
mostly cluster bomb spam there's also
been a few four man squads beating it
and once again either the whole team or
about half of them are using heavy bow
guns with cluster bombs the point I'm
trying to make is that an extreme
behemoth is only being one way so far
and then in for a game that says that
any weapon is viable
it's almost contradicting that statement
because of how powerful the cluster
bombs are and how strong behemoth is in
general especially when you're using a
melee type weapon because obviously if
you use a melee type weapon you're up
close and personal with him and that's
of course when he does some very high
damaging moves like a sort of ground
pound slam in the front the shoulder
charge check the meteor all that type of
good stuff that's going to be doing some
hefty damage to you so staying at range
is a good idea and that's why I only
think that this is only gonna be
promoting one style of play for this now
of course this is only like the first or
two you know one or two days since this
monster has been out so probably as time
goes on more people are going to start
defeating it and more people are going
to start finding different ways to use
it other than just heavy bow guns and
cluster bombs but still at like I said
at the time of
during this it's basically just been
cluster bomb spam everywhere let me know
what you guys think in the comments
below let me know how far you guys got
in this fight or if you'd be in extreme
behemoths before and if you have or even
if you haven't let me know what you guys
think of the rewards if it's even worth
it
personally but yeah like like I said
just let me know about that in the
comments but love to know your thoughts
so I'll just start a discussion down
there as well yeah I like the VP do
enjoy subscribe before new I covered the
informational side ba guys like the V
fiend do enjoy subscribe for new I
covered the solo guides of most of the
monsters in Monster Hunter world and I
do occasional discussion videos talking
about relevant topics throughout the
game and with that guys my two most new
vids will be on screen if you guys wanna
check that out when I got sober
yesterday think of Arts in the video and
peace out
[Music]